*Musique espagnole*
S : ¿ Holà qué tal amigos ?
Tu m'touches plus jamais.
F : Excellent.
S : Les amis aujourd'hui on est avec Florent Hauchard...
Bonjour !
F : Bonjour.
S : On revient du Japon, enfin on est revenu y'a un moment déjà, on est en forme. C'était cool, ça t'a plu ?
F : Écoute, c'était nul à chier.
Parlons-en !
Parlons-en ! S : Il est là !
Nous sommes sur "Tekken",
parce qu'on n'a pas dit à quel jeu on allait jouer !
Souvenez-vous on s'était affronté sur Tekken au Japon...
K.O. ! C'est Lucas !
C'est Lucas Hauchard !
Dans la vidéo j'avais mis que les moments où je gagnait.
Mais, il gagnait aussi beaucoup. *rire*
Donc Tekken, qui sort en France quand ?
F : Le...
S : Faux ! Le 2 juin, c'est le 2 juin !
On a aujourd'hui une version sous les yeux, euh...
parce que... Bandai Namco,
se sont dit :
''Putain leurs combats sont impressionnants, quand ils jouent ils sont trop forts ces deux mecs.''
F : C'est vrai.
On veut qu'ils montrent à la France entière comment ils jouent...
F : C'est vrai,
on a déjà montré au Japon comment on jouait.
S : Ouais et... et ce que je viens de te dire c'est faux par contre.
Je suis désolé.
Ils n'ont jamais dit ça.
Oh mais non, mais Florent, c'est une blag-... Mais Florent reviens !
Florent, tu touches 1.000€ pour faire cette vidéo.
F: j'arrive
S: *rire*
Je te propose pour ce premier combat,
un grand classique.
F : Un tour de chauffe.
S : Oh putain, t'es dans le tryhard là pour de vrai ?
F : Non, je suis dans, je suis dans le tour de chauffe !
S : Moi je te propose un "animals fight" d'entrée de jeu
pour nous mettre bien parce que les gens adorent les pandas.
Les gens adorent les ours
et ils adorent le kuma, l'épice.
et ton ours s'appelle ''kuma''.
F : Le cumin tu veux dire ?
S : Cette blague tombe à l'eau.
*rire*
F : Et baaah...
S : Panda/ours, qui gagne ? La réponse dans un instant.
Alors...
F : Excuse number one de mon frère au Japon ;
"oui mais je n'arrive pas à faire en bas jusqu'à droite,
j'ai l'impression que ça va vers la gauche ou en haut.''
S : C'est vrai que j'ai du mal, mec !
S : J'arrêtais pas de sauter je faisais pas exprès !
S : J'voulais juste-...
F : Ouaaaais je sais, je sais je sais.
Il y a le skill, le skill véritable, l'arcade.
S : Oui, bien sûr.
F : Et puis, et puis euh.... L'ours qui va te mettre une droite putain !
S : Ooh !
Oh tiens, tiens, tiens...
Fallait mettre fin , fallait mettre fin à la supercherie
*cri*
F : Oh non !   S : Et c'est raté
F: Oh il a esquivé
S: Ok le loup enragé
F et S : OHHHHHHHH
S : Eh frère j'suis dans le dernier clip de jul je suis dans le dernier clip de jul
*cri*
S : Oh putain c'est la vanne sur l'épice qui t'a pas plu ou....
S : Non bien joué je n'ai pas eu le réflexe
Là j'en ai marre ! Ah là tu me craques le dos comme quand on était petits
*rire*
S : Je  try-hard les amis
Le panda veut gagner un round
S : Non bien joué, anh "time up" toutes façons! Attends "time up" quoi
on en est là on joue tellement en mode défensive qu'on arrive au "time up"
F : Attention ! Le coup de pied du fourbe, le coup de pied du lâche, le gros coup de pied du lâche, voilà...
S : T'arrête d'être un lâche, putain mais les ours... ça a changé les ours
S : Oh putain, bien joué
F : Je suis par l'équipe de la Forest pour rien !  S : L' ours a le dessus sur le panda
S : Et il le mérite vu cette danse, clairement il le mérite
S : Bon alors maintenant
Combat à thème
F : On peut faire de manière sûre, gros seins
Ça va être des seins très larges sur votre personnage  50% du Game
S : Tu as dit gros seins ?
F : J'ai dit gros seins
S : Très bien
S : Il a des gros seins
F : J'étais sur mec !
F : j'étais sur en plus je sav...je... putain si je le prends pas il va le prendre cet enfoiré
F : Et bah du coup on va partir sur une...
S : Tu joues avec les flèches toi aussi celle-là ? F : Ouais je joue avec les flèches moi
S : Vous avez vu comment j'essaie d'apprendre petit à petit pour essayer de le battre ?
F : T'as d'autres questions ou ... S : Non c'est bon, c'est bon
F : Bah je vais prendre une petite Asuka
S : 4+7
F : euh 11 S: Excellent
S : Attention parce que là on rentre dans la phase sérieuse de jeu
F : Ah...ah. Alors ça
S : Alors F : Mec on avait dit pas de try-hard. Deuxième combat...
S : Chuttt... titutu
F : naaan   S : Ok. T'es prêt?   F : Bah non du coup
S : Allez vas-y
F : ça part sur un move list
S : Mec, non franchement... Tu veux que je sois franc avec toi?
F : Non   S : J'ai retenu aucun truc... frère sincèrement
F :  Okay j'ai retenu un move   S : pareil!
S : vas-y fait le tien
S : OH ! C'est pas mal !
S : Attend moi je te montre ce que c'est ?  F : Vas-y vas-y
S : Voilà...
S : *Rire*
F : OHOHOH !
F : OHLALA !  S : À oui j'aime trop celui-là F : Mec ça te fais une esquive
F : Incroyable ou pas ?!
S : Excellent !
S : Oh bien joué oh putain mec mais tu me défonces là ça va pas du tout
S : Oh j' y arrive plus avec la manette j' y arrive plus
S : Oh putain...
F : Oh..*rire*  S :  putain... je passe un très mauvais moment là
S : Oh non !
*Rire*
S : Hey j'étais prêt à esquiver, c'était furtif
S : Bon, celle-là on la refait parce que je veux m'habituer à Bob parce que la ça va pas du tout
S : j'ai l'impression que mes coups font moins mal qu'avant
F : Non c'est juste que...  S : tu... est-ce que mais juste tu peux me laisser trouver des excuses s'il te plait?
S : Mes coups font vraiment moins mal qu'avant j'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi, c'est bizarre et puis c'est bizarre voilà c'est un peu bizarre.  F : Ouais ouais ça doit forcément être ça... Ouai non mais voilà
SHUUU
S : Calmes-toi, calmes-toi
Ho putain, merde...
F : Ho, c'était beau ça !
S : PUTAIN ! Je charge mon gars!
Ho putain, bien joué...
Putain, c'est dur là
C'est dur ce qu'il se passe
Ah, je peux...
Ouhh...
HOOOOOOOOOOOOO
*rires*
Hoo, le beau jeu ! Abonnez-vous, abonnez-vous!
Tu n'es plus sur mon testament.
JE SUIS UN ILLUMINATI !!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!